[Música]
nuevamente el congreso peruano hace un
intento por destituir al presidente
Pedro Castillo el legislativo aprobó en
un comité un informe que recomienda
inhabilitarlo para ejercer cargos
públicos por 5 años y también su salida
de la presidencia veamos
se concluye acusarlo en su condición de
presidente de la república por la
presunta infracción del artículo 32 54
110 118 incisos 1 2 y 11 de la
constitución política del Perú y de
acuerdo al artículo 100 de la Carta
Magna propone que se le imponga la
sanción de inhabilitación por 5 años
para el ejercicio de la función pública
y acusarlo durante juicio político como
presunto autor del delito de traición a
la patria
la subcomisión de acusaciones
constitucionales aprobó por 11 votos a
favor y 10 en contra el informe que hace
una recomendación acusarlo de traición a
la patria Pero por qué la subcomisión
Consideró que el presidente ha cometido
un delito al mencionar que consultaría a
los peruanos sobre la posibilidad de
darle salida al mar a Bolivia un
comentario que hizo en una entrevista a
la cadena de noticias CNN en español El
hecho tuvo lugar cuando el periodista
Fernando del Rincón le preguntó al
presidente Castillo por ese mismo
comentario en el que pedía mar Para
Bolivia hace algunos años atrás antes de
que fuera presidente de la república
ante todas estas turbulencias Pedro
Castillo dio unas declaraciones veamos
no nos amilan a nosotros acá estamos por
el país porque antes que todo está el
ciudadano les decía y espero de que el
congreso de la República
actúe de Mirando al pueblo peruano esta
nueva remezón político ocurre cuando
Perú se prepara para recibir una
comisión de la Organización de Estados
Americanos oea que llegará a Lima el 20
de noviembre por pedido expreso del
mandatario la misión de estos enviados
de la oea es corroborar si la democracia
peruana está amenazada por fuerzas
golpistas o si por el contrario el mismo
gobierno es quien pone en peligro la
institucionalidad al estar Aparentemente
relacionado con una red de corrupción en
la que también estaría involucrado el
presidente Castillo otros hechos
destacados de los últimos días es la
profundización de la ya existente
polarización en el país entre la
sociedad peruana no es algo nuevo pero
las recientes manifestaciones evidencian
una fractura aún mayor cerca de 5000
personas salieron a las calles de Lima
para manifestar su descontento con el
gobierno de Castillo solamente cinco
días después miles de ciudadanos esta
vez no solamente en Lima sino también en
14 ciudades de Perú salieron para
respaldar la gestión de castillo
pero se mantiene en su eterna
encrucijada política a un congreso que
parece más concentrado en Buscar maneras
para destituir al presidente y un
mandatario que solo Busca maneras para
mantenerse en el poder un tira y afloje
que le hace daño a la institucionalidad
a la gobernabilidad a la democracia y se
olvida de lo más importante el pueblo
los peruanos quien dará su brazo a
torcer quien ganará este pulso entre
congreso y presidente Perú en su espiral
de crisis política lo analizamos en
France 24 Sí otra vez otra vez porque
esta historia continúa para conversar
sobre este tema hemos invitado a Ana
neira ella es profesora de derecho
constitucional en la universidad del
Pacífico y en la pontificia Universidad
Católica del Perú también es exministra
de justicia de Perú y también está con
nosotros José Carlos requena analista
político socio de la consultora público
y también columnista del diario el
comercio ustedes nuestros televidentes
Recuerden que también hacen parte del
debate pueden dejar sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales estamos en Twitter en Facebook
en Instagram donde se encuentran como
arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate f24 todo
junto todo pegado y no olviden también
que los contenidos del programa están
disponibles en diferentes plataformas de
podcast estamos en Apple podcast podcast
estamos también en Spotify en deezer y
en TuneIn Pues muy bien comienzo
entonces para conocer posiciones le doy
la palabra a Jorge Carlos requena José
Carlos Gracias por estar con nosotros
Gracias por acompañarnos en el programa
Y desde su análisis es válida esta
argumentación del congreso para acusar
nuevamente al presidente Castillo
Mira yo creo que se basa sobre sustentos
muy débiles
Y si bien es cierto el presidente dio
una declaraciones muy controversiales en
febrero pasado no ha habido ningún hecho
que complemente o que muestre su
voluntad teniendo él diciendo él el jefe
la de la política exterior peruana en su
calidad de presidente democráticamente
elegido no ha hecho decía ninguna ningún
acto que
ponga o que a mi juicio justifique una
acusación de la naturaleza de lo que
esta comisión ha aprobado y creo que la
verdad le hace un favor al presidente
porque va a terminar victimizándolo y
porque se está forzando una figura con
un sustento bien débil como decía al
inicio
y ahora le doy la palabra A Ana neira
Ana Bienvenida al programa también un
gusto tenerla con nosotros la misma
pregunta es esta argumentación
suficiente por parte del congreso para
acusar nuevamente al presidente Castillo
Cuál es su análisis bienvenida gracias
yo coincido con mucho de lo que hice
José Carlos en verdad de todas las
acusaciones que contra el presidente
Esta es sin duda la más débil creo que
no se hace un favor el congreso cuando
justamente con aquello que es más débil
porque efectivamente no ha llevado
ningún acto específico luego de la
entrevista con CNN el presidente para
entregar Mara Bolivia y decir que hay
traición a la patria es bastante débil y
además de que decirlo quienes
promovieron en su momento esta acusación
son quienes antes alegaban que había
habido fraude para que él fuera elegido
cosa que nunca se llegó a probar Pese a
que intentaron hacerlo entonces hay una
percepción de que aquí se está de alguna
manera fabricando una acusación contra
el presidente que
suficientemente fuerte y le quita un
mérito a otras que probablemente tengan
más asidero no Y además de Cara a la
misión creo que ayudan al gobierno a
poder fundamentar esto de que los están
atacando injustificadamente que no les
permiten gobernar Y entonces creo que la
oposición mal se ayuda con una cuestión
como esta para para justamente la semana
previa a la misión plantearlo no Ana
continuó con usted para preguntarle para
entender Para quienes no conocemos la
justicia y las leyes peruanas quienes
conforman esta comisión
Cómo ha sido este proceso para llegar a
esta acusación que ha aprobado el
congreso
y cualquier persona puede presentar una
denuncia constitucional aquí lo que han
alegado es que hay una infracción a la
Constitución supuestamente porque
producto de esta entrevista El
presidente habría intentado cederle mar
territorial peruano a Bolivia no Y esto
es para ellos traición a la patria no y
en ese sentido lo que ha ocurrido es que
una subcomisión dentro del Congreso hay
muchas comisiones como en todos los
modelos a nivel mundial Pero hay una
subcomisión específicamente que se
encarga de analizar las acusaciones
constitucionales no en este caso está su
comisión por 11 votos contra 10 además
en una posición muy dividida han
finalmente decidido que tiene mérito
esta acusación Y luego tiene que ir a la
comisión permanente que es este órgano
que se encarga según la Constitución de
acusar eventualmente altos funcionarios
iría luego el pleno para que votaran si
este informe se aprueba no no lo han
citado al presidente esta semana para
que haga sus descargos y seguro luego de
ello pasará ya a la comisión permanente
en en ese momento y luego al pleno para
que voten y ahí se decidirá así se
aprueba o no este ese informe Finalmente
y con ellos se le sitúa el presidente
como plantea la propuesta de este a su
comisión claro José Carlos ustedes ya
los dos han coincidido en que es una
acusación bastante débil contra el
presidente pero se está sacando una foto
fuera de contexto de la situación en
Perú para armar un motivo una motivación
para poder hacer esta acusación se está
simplemente sacando de contexto las
palabras del presidente para justificar
y armar un caso qué motivación pueden
tener
estas comisiones del congreso para poder
impulsar esta tercera acusación
Bueno sí Este es un proceso largo la
verdad es uno de los tantos flancos que
tiene abierto el presidente Castillo
creo que otros por ejemplo la acusación
de la fiscal de la nación creo que tiene
elementos más contundentes pero aún en
ese caso el recurso que se ha querido
usar a mí me parece forzado Creo que
este es el momento digamos mucho más
propicio para una figura mucho más
sensible también como es la vacancia
presidencial para eso se requiere un
umbral muy alto y es ante ese umbral que
la oposición está forzando estos estos
recursos que de nuevo creo que favorecen
o terminan favoreciendo al mandatario
con esa imagen de victimización
además teniendo algunos antecedentes de
un mal uso de las figuras que están
estipuladas en la Constitución esta yo
creo que no tiene ninguna otra
motivación que querer deshacerse de
Castillo creo que hay un amplio
porcentaje de la población que así lo
pero no creo que para ellos deba
forzarse las figuras como se está
tratando de hacer en el congreso y por
otro lado también la verdad se exponen a
una nueva derrota Porque si en la
subcomisión de constitucionales que es
la votación ha sido muy ajustada 11 a 10
con cuatro con cuatro los integrantes
que no votaron yo no creo que la
situación en el pleno vaya a ser holgada
a favor de la oposición De hecho cuando
uno hace la sumas y restas y el
oficialismo sigue teniendo una ventaja
considerable entonces forzar estas cosas
y no más bien dedicarse a lograr el
umbral que la que la vacancia requiere
creo que desgasta la oposición y creo
que los los ubique en una posición mucho
más incómoda José Carlos cuál sería
entonces el precio de forzar retoma esta
palabra que usted ha dicho en esta
intervención de este tire de afloje
congreso presidencia forzar este
desgaste de la institución de la
institucionalidad como tal esto Qué
consecuencias va a traer para la para la
democracia peruana y para la
institucionalidad en Sí cuando se está
forzando tanto los casos las
instituciones aprobar casos que no
tienen un sustento lo suficientemente
válido o fuerte
Mira la verdad yo creo que los últimos
cinco años han sido muy malos para la
institucionalidad Pero bueno porque sean
forjado se han forjado
noseado se han utilizado de manera
irresponsable muchas figuras tanto por
el lado de la vacancia como por el lado
de la de la cuestión de confianza este
sería un capítulo más Pero creo que
sería un capítulo extremo diría yo y en
consecuencia lo que podría venir el
precedente que se plantea es es muy
complicado para la institucionalidad que
como te decía ya está bastante
debilitado
pasó a preguntarle a Ana neyra La otra
cara de la moneda entonces para el
presidente Castillo Qué significa para
él llevar un poco más de un año en la
presidencia de Perú y pasarse todo el
tiempo en defensas de sus actos en
defensa de lo que ha dicho o de lo que
ha propuesto y acercar a este tipo de
acusaciones ustedes mencionan una
palabra en las intervenciones y es la
victimización el puede volver esta
victimización algo a favor para su
imagen como presidente que le pueda
garantizar de pronto llegar a buen
término de su periodo presidencial
yo creo que de alguna forma ya lo ha
hecho no sé si José Carlos coincidirá
con esa con ese enfoque pero creo que de
alguna manera ellos ya el gobierno
utiliza cualquier acusación cualquier
intento de cuestionamiento al presidente
como una como una supuesta o sea racismo
discriminación que no quieren un
presidente con sus características en el
en el gobierno y es posible que haya
elementos de ese tipo dentro de las
críticas pero tampoco podemos negar que
hay serias acusaciones de corrupción
contra el presidente y contra el
gobierno que cada vez parece tener más
cercanía con el propio presidente
círculo familiar sus exministros que él
no quería remover
Incluso se alega que había habido
entregas de dinero hacia él Entonces
digamos no es como que tampoco todo esto
sea simplemente un una acusación sin
fundamento para pretender sacarlo del
poder No es cierto que hay intentos
desde incluso antes el cual elegido de
que él no asuma y luego de que no sea
elegido presidente pero creo que él
también el gobierno le ha dado muchos
argumentos en la con su mala designación
de ministros y con una serie de actos
que cada vez parecen estar más cerca del
presidente y que implicarían actos de
corrupción no entonces
evidentemente lo que está pasando en
este momento es que como no se tienen
los votos pero la vacancia que son 87
votos en el congreso y el presidente ha
conseguido aliados que eventualmente le
permiten conseguir bastantes votos que
le aseguran no salir batatado lo que
está pasando por el otro lado Es que la
composición intenta otros mecanismos
algunos con mayor asidero que otros y el
gobierno por su lado utiliza estos
argumentos como diciendo bien Ven que
siempre me quisieron sacar no pero sin
contestar a las acusaciones serias que
se les hace por actos de corrupción que
también merecen obviamente una respuesta
porque tampoco deberíamos familiar esos
actos en el gobierno anda usted menciona
el número clave 87 que es lo necesario
para llegar a esa vacancia que busca el
congreso y que han buscado ya en otras
oportunidades
en los meses anteriores Cómo estarían
entonces las cargas equilibradas o
reorganizadas para este proceso si esto
tiene buen Puerto y
trasciende y llega hasta una votación a
un posible juicio político contra el
presidente donde tenga que votar una
vacancia de él
Sí yo creo que no tienen los votos
Porque si ellos supieran que tienen los
votos ya hubieran intentado la vacancia
directamente no es por eso que piensan
de mecanismos alternativos y es por eso
que tenemos hoy esta acusación por
traición a la patria que ellos entiendo
quieren aprobar con una o un menor o una
menor cantidad de votación Pese a que
esto no es tan claramente así no parece
que se exige una votación mayor pero en
todo caso lo que muchos analistas
políticos muchos muchas personas que
seguimos estos temas hemos sido
calculando Es que la votación no la
tienen Pues a nivel ellos quisieran
porque incluso hay que recordar que la
oposición también está medio dividida
porque hubo algunas inconvenientes con
ellos cuando se cambió la mesa directiva
entonces no es como un monolito en la
oposición que está lista para votar la
vacancia digamos eso no es noviembre del
20 cuando se convenció a 105 personas a
votar a favor de la danza no no estamos
en el escenario y por eso es que están
intentando encontrar alternativas ahora
el inconveniente que parece que el
formato que se está generando es un
pacto de permanencia no no un banco de
política pública ustedes mencionaban al
inicio que no estamos pues viendo
realmente preocupación por la ciudadanía
sino más bien por quedarse e incluso
quienes quieren sacar el presidente lo
que quieren es solo sacarlo a él pero no
irse ellos a pesar que la mayor parte de
la población o les dice que se pongan de
acuerdo o les dice que quieren que se
vayan todos no no están intentando
tampoco esos mecanismos jurídicos que en
el Perú ya se utilizaron en el año 2001
y sin embargo ahora lo que quieren más
bien el congreso es que se vaya el
presidente del gobierno Pero ellos
quedarse en el poder con el antecedente
Terrible que tenemos de noviembre del 20
de choza de paso hoy se recuerda
justamente dos años empezamos esta
marcha terrible con una reflexión
policial horrorosa que terminó de la
muerte dos personas y muchos heridos no
entonces
lamentablemente no presenta un poco
estar pensando en el impacto que podría
tener sacar un presidente
democráticamente elegido por por ese
tipo de mecanismos que la gente siente
muy arbitrarios claro es que aquí no
gozan con no con mucho prestigio ni
mucho aprecio por parte de la ciudadanía
ni el presidente ni el congreso como tal
también lo hemos visto en las
manifestaciones José Carlos su su
opinión sobre esta equilibrio de de
votaciones Y cómo estarían divididas las
cargas en una eventual votación cómo
está dividida allí en la votación en el
congreso en una eventual escenario de
una vacancia
Bueno es un escenario muy muy lejano No
güey cuando uno se sumas y restas la
oposición está más o menos entre 35 y 40
votos de alcanzar el umbral que que te
mencionábamos de 87 votos
eso es la verdad yo coincido con con Ana
en el sentido de que lo que busca la
ciudadanía es más bien o por lo menos la
mayor porcentaje es que el Perú se
dirige a un escenario de elecciones
anticipadas Y eso no tiene que ver
solamente por eso no tiene que ver
solamente con la remoción de castillos
sino o la remoción de un congreso que
termina siendo o termina
jugando de cómplice de este pacto infame
que que podemos llamar para aceptar a un
ensayista peruano Manuel González Prada
que tiene que ver con sobrevivir No yo
no creo que haya ninguna voluntad
positiva de hecho hablaba yo de
institucionalidad y el presidente
Castillo en los 15 o 16 meses que llega
el cargo también se dedicaba a minarla
removiendo ministros que él eran
incómodos reviviendo procuradores y
tratando de someter a las fuerzas
armadas utilizando la el servicio de
inteligencia para poder
controlar de alguna manera los
opositores en fin Hay muchísimas
acciones Más allá de la de la
incapacidad para gobernar Más allá de
las acusaciones de corrupción también
hay mucho daño a la institucionalidad en
eso 16 meses que tendría que corregirse
de alguna manera y que esperemos que se
corrijan en el breve plazo
lamentablemente no es eso que y vea yo
algo en el Horizonte muy cercano a ver
como esto es un escenario hipotético
estamos acá moviéndonos un poco dentro
del terreno de la especulación porque
este caso puede trascender o no puede
llegar a ese juicio político como lo
decía José Carlos es un escenario que es
factible pero pues todavía falta algunas
partes en ese proceso es importante
entender la situación de Perú y la
situación del presidente Castillo porque
desde afuera de las fronteras peruanas
los titulares que vemos y que acaparan
la prensa internacional es justamente
cuando hay otro caso en contra del
presidente Castillo Cuál es el truco que
han hecho para organizar Entonces el
caso como lo presentan Y qué hace el
presidente para defenderse pero José
Carlos cómo está Perú en este momento
salen de la pandemia de Kobe 19 y todos
estos altibajos políticos como repercute
en el día a día del peruano en el
desarrollo económico en levantar la
economía del país y en esa estabilidad
social y política
Pues mira fíjate las crisis de los
últimos años parece que haber apartado a
los peruanos de la política cotidiana En
consecuencia Yo te diría que de hecho
las cifras más recientes del instituto
de estudios peruanos de hace un par de
meses hablaban de una reducción hasta de
20 puntos porcentuales entre la gente
que le importaba poco o algo la política
no entonces la verdad eso también se ha
visto en las marchas que ustedes están
mostrando en imágenes son marchas que en
el mejor de los casos para ambos lados
llevaban a 10.000 personas en un país de
33 millones de personas es un número muy
reducido Incluso si se le compara con
las masivas marchas de noviembre del
2020 o algunas de años previos entonces
hay una gran apatía y yo te diría que el
grueso de la población sigue con su vida
como si nada pasara creo que
el malestar económico en algún momento
va a empezar a sentirse con mayor con
mayor profundidad pero por ahora te
diría que una discusión que sobre todo
nos interesa a los que nos interesa la
política no los analistas abogados
periodistas
inversores en fin Pero el ciudadano ya
pide te diría que tiene un hartazgo
hacia la política Entonces lo mantiene
lejos y hace que también participe menos
en las manifestaciones públicas a pesar
de que las cifras de las encuestas
hablan de una gran insatisfacción tanto
con el presidente como con el congreso
Ana y cuál es su opinión de la foto
completa del panorama peruano
Sí bueno Yo también creo que la
ciudadanía digamos general tampoco es
que esté siguiendo todos los días de
castillos se queda si el congreso
interpretó de una manera o la otra pero
sí es cierto de que esta creo constante
constante enfrentamiento entre ambos
poderes hace que quiten su atención de
los problemas realmente relevantes no
por ejemplo en el Perú a pesar de todo
las intentos del gobierno hasta este
momento no se logra comprar
fertilización es una cosa tan menor para
la agricultura que podría ayudarnos en
la crisis alimentaria que está surgiendo
aquí en varios otros países del mundo no
no se logra por ejemplo tomar medidas
más o menos estructuradas contra la
inflación que nos está repercutiendo por
la guerra Ucrania rusa y así varias
otras cosas que parece ser más bien como
están más preocupados o en sacar a uno o
a quedarse todos no están atendiendo no
evidentemente esto hoy todavía no lo
siente de manera tan directa a la
ciudadanía Pero conforme la escasez se
vuelva mayor conforme la pobreza se
agrave a veces se podría hacer el efecto
gatillador que en tantos países ha sido
Eso es tipo de cuestiones y ahí tal vez
comprometer un poco más a la ciudadanía
igual Es cierto que la la protesta no es
pues una protesta masiva no estamos
viendo a todo el mundo saliendo ninguna
de las marchas ni la primera que quiere
sacar a Castillo ni la segunda que
quiere que se mantenga ha tenido
realmente una convocatoria masiva ni
siquiera una convocatoria como la de
noviembre del 20 o como antes en el en
los cuatro suyos no en realidad hemos
tenido convocatorias bastante modestas
es cierto importantes pero no
multitudinarias y tiene que ver con
varios factores no probablemente porque
tiene ese movilista son más de la
izquierda etcétera no pero digamos en
este momento creo que no tenemos todavía
un clamor ciudadano masivo de salida de
todos pero sí una sensación me parece de
que esta situación se está por lo menos
para quienes lo seguimos en el día a día
que se va grabando y como antes decía
también José Carlos que va afectando una
de todo lo que está pasando en los
últimos ya cinco o seis años
Ana eso en cuanto a la fotografía
general del panorama en Perú pero que
hay del protagonista de toda esta
historia el presidente Pedro castillo de
acuerdo a una encuesta hecha durante el
mes de octubre el presidente cuenta con
una aprobación solamente del 28%, 62% de
impopularidad entre los peruanos que
balance de gestión hacia usted de estos
meses que lleva Castillo en el en la
presidencia de Perú
quién me parece una una cuestión que ha
estado sobre todo centrada en gesto no
es el presidente campesino es el
presidente que ha sido maestro es el
presidente que viene de zonas de pobreza
pero en realidad si nos ponemos analizar
Qué medidas compré esta tomado para
estos sectores la verdad es que yo creo
que las podemos contar con los dedos de
la mano y esto es no Entonces a mí lo
que me una de las cosas que me parece
que que marca su cuestión es una
cuestión de mucha palabra y poca acción
no una gestión en la cual realmente creo
que la ciudadanía no recibe los efectos
de este presidente que supuestamente
goberna para el pueblo no y más bien se
toman una serie de medidas más bien
populistas como en su momento pretender
expulsar extranjeros sobre todo
venezolanos o bajar la edad de
criminalidad a los 14 años porque así
dicen que van a van a ir contra la
Seguridad Ciudadana o a enfrentar las
inseguridad ciudadana entonces realmente
no se perciben políticas públicas
encaminadas a
resolver los verdaderos problemas de
ciudadanos y del pueblo que él
supuestamente representan José Carlos y
su balance del presidente
Bueno es muy parecido no yo creo que han
sido 16 meses 15 16 meses muy malos
en La cantidad es funcionarios que han
estado en cada sector más de 70 personas
nombradas de ministros en solo 14 meses
escándalos cada tres días según reportar
el diario el comercio Hace unos días
y la popularidad te diría que tiene una
mejor performance hasta ahora de lo que
tenía Toledo el tema es que no tiene un
equipo y tiene otras prioridades
claramente no
José Carlos aquí quien tiene mayor
desaprobación o quién genera mayor
descontento entre los peruanos el
presidente Castillo o el congreso de la
República mira en términos fríos en los
números el congreso es más impopular que
el presidente no el congreso
naturalmente es impopular y lo digo en
globalmente
este congreso tiene el punto en contra
que no está haciendo un o está haciendo
solo parcialmente un contrapeso a lo que
hace el mandatario
Sí entiendo Pues el 20 de noviembre se
espera que llegue a la Ciudad de Lima
una misión una comisión de la
Organización de Estados Americanos que
ha sido solicitada justamente por el
presidente Castillo para evaluar si la
democracia peruana está en riesgo o no o
si por el contrario la misma
institucionalidad peruana está en riesgo
debido al gobierno que está en este
momento en el poder este escenario con
este nuevo caso en marcha Ana aquí que
tanto puede repercutir en esta misión
que Qué foto van a ver ellos teniendo
este nuevo proceso contra el presidente
yo creo que que el presidente
consigue con esto sin haber hecho
absolutamente nada gratuitamente el
congreso le da al presidente una
herramienta para que diga justamente por
eso activamos la carta democrática
porque no nos pretenden gobernar porque
nos quieren sacar por una cuestión
absolutamente injustificada no pero creo
que también el gobierno tiene que ser
consciente que la misión va a evaluar
pues toda la situación no solamente esta
específica acusación sino todas las
acusaciones de corrupción va a evaluar
el tratamiento del gobierno a la prensa
que no es precisamente muy favorable la
libertad de información y de expresión
muy por el contrario no tienen ellos un
constante enfrentamiento y hasta yo
diría maltrato a la prensa no entonces
creo que el gobierno piensa que con la
activación de la carta solo va a poner
los reflectores frente al congreso Pero
no se dan cuenta que también se va a
poner los reflectores a sí mismo y que
el balance al final sí es cierto que el
congreso lo ayuda pero que de todas
maneras es va a ser equilibrado y
tendrán que ver todo lo que está pasando
en el Perú por un lado
y José Carlos su opinión que que se va a
encontrar esta comisión de la oea y
desde su análisis citando algunas de las
palabras del presidente Castillo si hay
intentos de golpe allí en Perú con los
hechos que hemos visto en los últimos
meses
creo que hay intento de forzar algunas
cosas sin duda Pero también la palabra
golpe sea se ha utilizado con con mucha
responsabilidad y hay momentos
evidentemente han sido abusos de algunas
figuras pero hablar de golpe como tal a
mí me parece forzado en cualquier caso
creo que el único escenario de golpe que
ha habido como tal es el que se dio a la
disolución del parlamento por parte del
presidente vizcarra Ese fue un golpe
ejecutivo claramente pero en cualquier
caso en la situación actual
la misión va a tener que escuchar a a
todos los los actores como bien
mencionaba Ana y Eso incluye a
instituciones en la sociedad civil y de
la prensa no la prensa ha sido
maltratada Casi casi una vez por semana
en algunos casos Incluso se librantando
algunos simpatizantes del presidente
teniendo ahí a a periodistas a
integrantes prensa al alcance de los
manifestantes no Entonces
eso habrá que que contrapesarlo y habrá
que ver con qué tanta autonomía actúa
esta esta misión es
hay cinco cancilleres en funciones yo
creo que a ningún canciller le gusta
estar enemistado con algún país en
particular y esperemos que sea lo más
objetiva posible no y no se preste Más
bien a prolongar esta situación que no
le hace bien ni al país ni a lo político
llegamos al bloque final de el programa
momento para hacer las conclusiones de
lo que puede suceder en Perú creo que
las voy a hacer la pregunta del millón
de dólares a José Carlos y Ana y es que
puede salir Qué puede sacar a Perú de
esta espiral de crisis política que
llevamos viendo tantos años y que ha
generado tanta inestabilidad y tanta
mala prensa e imagen para Perú a nivel
internacional comenzó con José Carlos y
termino con Ana para el cierre
Bueno yo creo que en lo inmediato creo
que que tratar de llegar a un escenario
de selecciones anticipadas que además
cuenten con con reglas básicas que
incluyan promover la participación lo
más amplia posible
creo que eso podría mejorar la situación
no una un modo optimista de verlo es que
y yo siento que estamos en la peor
crisis
por lo menos política no digo económica
porque la verdad la economía como que ha
sabido sobreponerse pero en términos
políticos estamos en un grado de
polarización
que tendríamos que superar en algún
momento no Y creo que eso pasa por por
tender puentes Por propiciar espacio de
diálogo y también por no dejar que la
impunidad
se asiente no yo creo que eso es
fundamental la opinión de José Carlos
requena elecciones anticipadas
participación más amplia Ana Cuál es la
suya para el cierre del programa
si yo yo coincido creo que en lo
inmediato es lo que tenemos que tratar
de lograr como consenso el congreso no
parece estar muy
abierto a esta idea entonces va a ver
que encontrar algún mecanismo que desde
la sociedad civil desde la ciudadanía
pueda de alguna manera obligarlos a una
solución en la cual repentemos todo no
volvamos a elegirlos a todos y no
solamente quieran ellos sacar al
gobierno no en creo además que es
importante que se disputan Rey las
mínimas en algún momento hemos hablado
de que la bicameralidad es importante
que podemos que podamos evitar que que
la prohibición de reelección se mantenga
porque ahora lo que hace es que llegue
mucha gente por poquito tiempo que
quiere más bien sacar todo lo posible en
el periodo que se queda no y creo que
ese tipo de cuestiones nos van a poder
ayudar progresivamente por supuesto con
mucha acción de diferentes sectores para
ir superando la crisis progresión pues
Ana Le agradezco mucho por este análisis
Lo mismo para José Carlos a los dos
gracias por haber estado en el programa
un capítulo más esta historia no termina
acá seguramente lo vamos a estar
retomando en algunas semanas meses
porque esta crisis política en Perú
continúa es todo por el momento Gracias
a ustedes por la sintonía En nombre del
equipo técnico Les agradecemos haber
estado con nosotros la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Giovanni
agudelo y la producción de invitados a
cargo de Tania Herrera sigan dejando sus
comentarios en las redes sociales
[Música]